leave that one for a little bit because
we do have a guest winner here in round
number four ilya nishnik one of the
strongest players of the area has
defeated camille dragoon ilya how's it
feel
uh pretty good finally i won a winning
position he was
great it started off in round number one
against sam savion you were on the back
foot at the beginning but after that you
came back and it ended up in a draw and
uh after that you had another very
pleasant edge against lenderman i think
right well no in the first game i
believe i was i was in a little bit of a
trouble after the opening and i don't
think sam was ever in trouble the game
number two was what uh what i'm still
kind of uh hating myself for it was a
just a completely winning position where
i had an extra rook and
and then yeah just hunts against hans
yeah against hans neiman and
what happened in the escape on his side
exactly yeah
he he he mentioned his uh his um the
game where he escaped down the queen but
it was a very similar pawn structure
there was there was this game queen
versus knight exactly i believe he
played in um and he won he not only
escaped
he won that yeah exactly exactly so uh
hans has experienced playing dumb
material and as he as he claimed after
the game he's really good with knights
so well we're not in the past right now
you won a beautiful game today how does
that feel uh it was it was actually yeah
it came came down to be a very
interesting game my opponent surprised
me was his opening choice to go for a
sideline in english
move number number two bishop b4 is what
my opponent played and i was honestly
not prepared
um
trying to remember my analysis
i couldn't do it played what seemed to
be logical moves and it somehow it
worked out so yeah i believe the
critical point of the game is if you go
back a couple more moves before
my opponent allowed me to play c5 i
believe that that probably uh camille
did not or
probably he either did not cc5 or
greatly underestimated the idea and um
he can actually play bishop h3 whenever
he wants and that's the point so if if
he just wants to play bishop h3 which i
agree should be his main plan here
because i have a bishop her advantage so
trading bishops by playing bishop h3
does make sense however allowing c5 is
is is
not exactly uh
the way to go in my mind so if ever him
instead of playing bishop h3 immediately
i would have played b6
so just
stopping c5
and the problem the problem here with my
position is that i have a very nice
looking center but those pawns never
never get to move anywhere so i can't
play d4 right now
and
hey because the pawn on c4 is hanging
and uh if my opponent plays bishop h3
that would be let's see let's see if i
make a make a random good looking move
such as
i'm not sure if that's a good looking
move but how about the queen e2
now if my opponent plays bishop h3 takes
takes
yeah takes takes and here i can try to
play d4 but now after i go d4 i
immediately get an issue with a c4 pawn
so i believe that my opponent's uh play
here will be based upon
putting a lot of pressure against a c4
pawn by playing maybe knight a5 going
back queen e6 and i wasn't sure what's
going to happen i believe that i would i
would have probably had to
do this if i wanted to win but yeah i
was
i was hesitant
fortunately for me uh uh yeah camille
camille missed on the c5 id and now my
play is just extremely straightforward
and we do see a result that we had
expected abhimanyu mishra has defeated
his opponent that makes a two in a row
for the youngster
two in a row after uh did he lose two
the first no he
he lost one he lost one against jj and
he drew this uh the first one and i
think he drew the first game yes that is
true
so back to the game uh where did you
feel was the decisive mistake after that
or was it just a slow build i i honestly
i felt like it just went downhill for
camille from this point on his he
started spending time and he he suddenly
he realized how unpleasant this idea is
yeah because probably queen d7 was or
might have been
uh a slight an accuracy although i
honestly do not really know what what
else because the d5 is coming and i
don't think black ever wants to take on
c5 because
i would i'm not even sure if i would
have taken the pawn back because the
idea of d5 yeah like yeah exactly so
instead of queen d7 if you can go back
one movie so if black takes on c5 right
now i was planning to play d5
and uh and i just have so much pressure
and all these central pawns is what what
gives me
so much space uh combined with a very
powerful bishop on the f4 i believe this
this might actually i might actually
have a decisive advantage at this point
already so um i honestly don't know what
what black should have done instead of
queen d7 it seems it seems tough those
knights are just uh exactly really
stepping on each other's right
so yes and here after i play d5 i'm not
actually i'm not i'm i'm not very happy
with with uh with how i played this
position out
everything i did looked logical but but
still i didn't have or i didn't feel i
didn't i didn't have as much as i would
like to have as much advantage as i
would like to have if that makes any
sense yeah so here i have an amazing
pawn structure and and and my main
strength here is that even if yeah so
this move c6 as i made i'm
or right here yeah i'm not sure i
couldn't i was trying to make it work
without playing c6
but it just it just wasn't working
somehow
black would always get to trade both
both of the c pawns and i couldn't
even that position i'm pretty sure
without without
the c pawns would probably be slightly
better for me but i just i just
yeah there was a really a judgment call
here i decided to go for for for this
structure where uh obviously the the
space is my main strengths and uh
the only my only issue with this
position is that if black somehow
manages to get their net over to d6 here
um
it's not going to be as clear anymore
because the only way to do that is via
e7 c8 or h8 f7 exactly this is exactly
why i included the movenet f3 earlier so
that the knight has to go back to so so
that the knight has to go to g6 right
right here actually the engine does not
really like the movement h6 surprisingly
even so i said that was the only move
here
i guess maybe he just wants to give up
the pawn no i guess
the alternative was to take on c5 but i
i believe it would be
black would get himself himself in
trouble by by having this this double
pawn structure and
yeah i just felt wrong so i was i was
totally expecting everything has
happened and here you hear i suddenly
realized that i i i missed i missed my
ponderous counterplay so here my
original plan was to play knight d2
right now
knight to f4 maybe yeah exactly 94 was
what i vastly underestimated and here
there's this one knight c4
uh-huh
all right let's take a look at how the
game more or less ended because it seems
that
he didn't get a lot of counter play
after it just seems
his position was paralyzed yeah well i
think i could have won faster at one at
one moment so if you go a couple of
moves forward
yeah it takes an e3
yeah i missed night that shade not have
seven ideas so here if i just want to
avoid the shade knight f7 i should just
play rookie one first and i believe the
difference is that my rook gets to a7
and i'll have queen e7 in the end so i
will i'll apply a lot of pressure on the
seventh string not in time to get to d6
yeah and black is not it's one move too
short to get there knight to d6 because
the c74 so i think this was
i i i was
i was very unhappy with myself that i
missed such an easy plan and after
another five actually black is right on
time
it's probably still losing because once
again
i think this g4 move is very important
because i i want to make sure that after
black captures on the five i recaptured
the g pawn
thus creating myself uh creating another
point of entrance for myself which is a
g file
so at this point i think camille was in
in a in a time pressure and he
he he tried doing something but
it's it's really difficult
it's really difficult when you can
barely move especially with no time we
do have another recirculator for you has
one
won
against uh jj ali morandi the youngsters
on our role today here in group b
nice actually i didn't expect
christopher to win he looked like he
might have been a little bit of a
trouble there but
that's discussion for another time i
guess he pulled he pulled the through
what first one yeah i'm extremely happy
with myself and what can i say yeah and
this is just crushing right beautiful
game ilya always a pleasure to see you
breaking through and uh good luck in the
rest of your games thank you so much so
much sharon thank you alejandra thank
you for joining us here for